I think that lovely introduction was
filmed three days ago back when I was
still young and promising and it wasn't
six o'clock in the morning I'm sorry
there's not going to be a question
Tuesday today I'll do it soon but in the
meantime let's kick it old school good
morning Hank it's Tuesday July first and
as you can tell from the great speckled
walls behind me I'm in an airport get
used to these walls Hank you're going to
be seeing a lot of them between now and
October so Hank you may be wondering why
I sound like Kermit the Frog with late
stage emphysema it's because I've spent
the last five days talking I've been
here in sunny an Han California for the
American Library Association annual
conference which is like Oh has as the
TSA limited the items that can be
carried onto the flight
thanks for that helpful information TSA
I don't know how I would have known it
if you hadn't said it four minutes ago
and four minutes before that and four
minutes before that and indeed every
four minutes that I'm in an airport in
my entire life which is of course a full
20 % of the time but anyway Hank I've
been at a LA conference reading books
and talking about books and thinking
about books nerdfighters and whenever I
go to LA conference I get so excited
that I like literally cannot shut up for
four days I mean Hank this is
consistently the most fun I have
professionally every year because I love
librarians they are so fun to hang out
with librarians are like the secret
superheroes of the world the conference
was absolutely fantastic and I had a
great time but one funny thing did
happen to me so is that the convention
signing copies of Looking for Alaska and
in abundance of katherines and generally
Hank it must be said that when you're
signing autographs for people they like
your book like that's why they're
standing in line to have it signed and
everyone was nice except for this one
woman she was this very sweet looking
old lady and she handed me your copy of
Looking for Alaska and she said I really
loved the first half of your novel but
the second half that just completely
fell apart and I was like well I really
liked the first half of your comment
other than the lady who didn't like the
second half of Looking for Alaska my
conference was mostly people coming up
to me and saying where's Hank is Hank
here did you bring Hank and the answer
to all of those questions Hank is of
course that you could not be at a La
convention this year because you were
busy training your
body and mind to get in shape for
meeting tens of billions of nerdfighters
on the great American tour de
nerdfighting 2008 in which awesome shall
happen IRL Hank speaking of awesome I
continued to be amazed how much you and
the nerdfighters and also all the
librarians in the world are made out of
it